una derrota con gusto a victoria siempre
he querido interpretar la jornada
electoral de esta noche aquí en el
comando de marín open empezando por la
propia candidata que cuando salió a
analizar los resultados y agradecer a
sus seguidores se sintió profundamente
tocada por la votación obtenida en
ultramar en el campo y en la provincia
ya dijo he sido la voz de los
silenciados agradeció sobre todo esos
votos que consiguió entre la primera y
segunda vuelta e impulsada por esta
votación histórica de la extrema derecha
propuso su nueva batalla que será las
elecciones legislativas de junio de este
año entre los votantes de marín le pen
que se encontraban esta noche aquí en el
bosque de boulogne había justamente eso
una sensación de decepción por la
derrota pero también una felicidad por
un resultado histórico para una
candidata salida de la extrema derecha
además
un contexto de alta abstención política
así que la batalla no ha hecho sino
comenzar para marino el joven que ahora
tiene sus ojos puestos en junio